html5 added types for in phone numbers
email addresses URLs numbers and dates
among others for each one of these
fields I can go in and the dev tools and
change it for example email right now
gives me the standard keyboard but if I
go in and change its type to email you
may notice one subtle difference I now
get an at symbol on my keyboard by
default some of the biggest changes were
four dates where I now get an actual
calendar and colors we're not only do I
get a nice color selection box but I can
actually edit the color and finally
there's a simple number input type
you'll notice this is somewhat like the
number input for telephone numbers
except there's no alphanumerics and
there's no hash and star sign